du wirst dumm süchtig und schizophren
das ist so ein bisschen der Eindruck den
man bekommt wenn man sich über die
Gefahren von Cannabis informieren möchte
Daniela Ludwig hatte also vielleicht gar
nicht so unrecht nur weil Alkohol
gefährlich ist unbestritten ist Cannabis
nicht ungefährlich okay denn Cannabis
beeinflusst das Gehirn das soll es ja
auch und deswegen ist es so beliebt aber
genau darin bestehen eben auch Risiken
wir denken dass die Legalisierung von
Cannabis genau der richtige Weg ist aber
mit Freiheit kommt eben auch
Verantwortung für sich selbst und für
andere deshalb haben wir uns gefragt
kann das Gehirn durch Cannabis permanent
beeinträchtigt werden gefährdet man
durch sein Cannabiskonsum auch
unbeteiligte Dritte und wie groß ist die
Gefahr dass dein nächster joint eine
Psychose triggert die Antworten auf all
diese Fragen und was die Wissenschaft
sagt wie man Cannabis verantwortungsvoll
genießen kann genau darüber sprechen wir
jetzt
kurzer Disclaimer dieses Video hier
ersetzt keine ärztliche Beratung einen
Fachartikel zum sicheren Umgang mit
Cannabis findet ihr in den Quellen
genauso wie alle anderen Fachartikel die
wir für dieses Video hier gelesen haben
und im Zweifelsfall findet euch bitte an
eure lokale Drogenberatung okay fangen
wir an THC und CBD und noch etwa 100
andere Stoffe in der Cannabispflanze
entfalten ihre Wirkung indem sie ins
endokranabinoid-system reingrätschen was
ist das das sind verschiedene Teile
unterschiedlicher biochemischer
Mechanismen und Systeme im Körper zum
Beispiel Immunsystem und Nervensystem
alles etwas kompliziert und für uns
heute auch gar nicht so wichtig wichtig
ist vor allem dass bestimmte Neuronen in
bestimmten Gehirnregionen von
Cannabinoiden beeinflusst werden denn
die Neuronen haben Proteine in ihrer
Zellmembran an die die Droge binden kann
diese Proteine nennt man
cannabinoid-rezeptoren und davon gibt es
verschiedene Versionen wenn zum Beispiel
THC an den sogenannten
cannabinoid-rezeptor 1 bindet dann
schüttet das Neuron weniger
Neurotransmitter aus als normalerweise
das sorgt dann unter anderem dafür dass
man so ein bisschen gechillter ist das
ist die stark vereinfachte Fassung wie
hier erstmal reichen muss der Punkt ist
wenn man natürliche oder synthetische
Cannabinoide konsumiert fuscht man damit
direkt an seine Neuronen und
Hirnfunktionen herum das machen alle
Drogen ja zum Beispiel auch Alkohol
natürlich aber auch Cannabis und das hat
eben nicht nur angenehme folgen
THC
Tetrahydrocannabinol ist für den Rausch
verantwortlich es stockt an einen
Rezeptor den man vor allem im
Belohnungssystem und inkognitiven
Arealen findet entsprechend sind bei
einem Rausch die Lernfähigkeit das
Gedächtnis und die Aufmerksamkeit
beeinträchtigt deshalb sind Leute die
bekifft Autofahren auch häufiger als
andere in Verkehrsunfälle verwickelt bei
den Menschen verletzt oder getötet
werden die Statistik für Alkohol sieht
zwar noch schlimmer aus ich glaube wir
sind uns einig dass man sich und andere
nicht unnötig gefährden sollte wie lange
man das Auto stehen lassen sollte das
wird durch viele Faktoren beeinflusst
z.B wie viel von welchen Cannabis
Produkten man wie konsumiert wie
regelmäßig man konsumiert und wie alt
man ist und in welchem Alter man damit
begonnen hat ein Beispiel gerauchtes
cannabis kann einen Rausch für 6 bis 8
Stunden bewirken während ein Ende will
also gegessen das Cannabis einen Rausch
von 8 bis 12 Stunden bewirkt übrigens
bei adible die Wirkung auch verzögert
ein deshalb kommt es da eher dazu dass
man mehr isst als man vorhatte beim
joint tritt der Rausch viel schneller
ein dafür ist Rauchen oder Welpen nicht
gut für das Atemsystem insbesondere
natürlich wenn man Tabak dazu braucht
das natürlich noch viel schlimmer aber
viel Kiffer schneiden sogar nüchtern
durchschnittlich schlechter in
kognitiven Tests ab als nicht Kiffer
betroffen sind da vor allem Funktionen
wie das Arbeitsgedächtnis und
Selbstkontrolle aber auch Bewegungs- und
sprachliche Fähigkeiten das Cannabis
konsumierende im Bildungssystem
schlechter abschneiden das lässt sich
zusätzlich auch auf fehlende Motivation
zurückführen es gibt Hinweise dass
intensiver Konsum zu einem Mangel an
Dopamin in einem zentralen Hirngebiet
dem sogenannten striatum führt und damit
zu Motivationsverlust zum Glück können
diese Fähigkeiten über einige Wochen und
Monate hinweg wieder zurückkehren wenn
man mit Cannabis aufhört z.B
verbesserten sich die Leistungen von
Studierenden an der Uni Maastricht als
der Verkauf von Cannabis an Menschen
ohne Wohnsitz in den Niederlanden
verboten wurde damals riecht im
Grenzland liegt wohne nämlich viele der
Studierenden in Deutschland super
wichtig ist aber auch dass es eben nicht
nur darauf ankommt wie lange man schon
kifft sondern auch in welchem Alter man
damit angefangen hat
denn das endokranabinoidsystem ist auch
an der Entwicklung des Gehirns von
Jugendlichen und jungen Erwachsenen
beteiligt zum Beispiel spielt es eine
Rolle beim Wachstum von Neuronen über
die Zeit während und nach der Pubertät
sinkt die Anzahl der
cannabinoid-rezeptoren im Gehirn
entsprechend haben Jugendliche
langanhaltende Beeinträchtigungen durch
Cannabiskonsum aber Erwachsene eher
nicht darüber hinaus wird es schwierig
mit der Interpretation der
Forschungsergebnisse wenn wir über
Langzeitfolgen von Cannabiskonsum im
Jugendalter sprechen zwar gibt es einige
Studien in denen früher Cannabiskonsum
mit veränderten Hirnstrukturen und
aktivitätsmustern im Gehirn korreliert
aber man kann mit Menschen keine
strengen kontrollierten Versuche machen
deshalb ist jeder Teilnehmer und jede
Teilnehmerinnen anders und bei den
allermeisten kann man eben nicht
eindeutig sagen ob eine Veränderung
wirklich ausschließlich auf Cannabis
zurückzuführen ist vielleicht liegt es
ja doch am Alkoholkonsum die Autoren
dieser Mieter Analyse hier Mandanten
sogar das Veränderungen im Gehirn bei
einigen Teilnehmern und Teilnehmerinnen
schon vorhanden waren bevor sie
überhaupt mit dem Cannabiskonsum
angefangen hatten dann könnte ihre
Gehirnstruktur die Ursache für ihren
Konsum sein oder beides hat eine
gemeinsame unbekannte Ursache der Punkt
ist wir wissen es einfach nicht eines
ist aber sicher wenn man tagtäglich
Cannabis konsumiert dann ist man
eigentlich immer kognitiv beeinträchtigt
und schlechte Leistungen in der Schule
an der Uni oder in der Ausbildung können
sicher auf lange Sicht auch negativ auf
die Zukunft auswirken aber die
vermutlich erschreckendste Gefahr von
der ihr vielleicht schon gehört hat ist
das Cannabis Psychosen und sogar
Schizophrenie auslösen kann
in einer psychotischen Episode erleiden
Betroffene einen Realitätsverlust
Halluzinationen und Wahnvorstellungen
aber auch desorganisiertes verhalten wie
zum Beispiel spontanes entkleiden oder
grundloses schreiben das hat nichts mit
einem party-haid zu tun betroffene
leiden darunter teilweise so stark dass
sie Angststörungen und schwere
Depressionen entwickeln solche Episoden
können von äußeren Einflüssen ausgelöst
werden dazu gehören emotionale
Stresssituationen wie der Verlust des
Arbeitsplatzes Auszug aus dem Elternhaus
oder Liebeskummer aber eben auch
Substanzen wie Cannabis können
psychotische Episoden triggern das kann
dann bis zu einer diagnostizierten
Schizophrenie führen wenn eine Droge in
einer Person eine Psychose auslöst die
dann aber nach beenden des Konsums in
den nächsten Monaten wieder weggeht
spricht man von einer Substanz
induzierten Psychose wenn die Psychose
mehr als 6 Monate nach dem letzten
Cannabiskonsum anhält dann kann sie als
Schizophrenie diagnostiziert werden
der wichtigste Risikofaktor für
Psychosen und Schizophrenie ist aber
eine genetische Veranlagung also wenn
man Menschen in der Verwandtschaft hat
die an Psychosen leiden männer und
Frauen sind gleich häufig betroffen aber
bei Männern treten die ersten Psychosen
meistens früher auf nämlich vor dem 20
Lebensjahr bei Frauen zwischen 20 und 25
Menschen die wegen Cannabis oder einer
anderen Substanz eine Psychose erleiden
sollten auf jeden Fall danach mit dem
Konsum aufhören denn wir aufhört hat
eine gute Chance dass er in Zukunft
seltener psychotische Episoden erleidet
als jemand der weiter konsumiert ob aber
Menschen ohne genetische Veranlagung
auch Gefahr laufen Psychosen zu
entwickeln das ist ungeklärt insgesamt
betrifft es wohl zu wenig Menschen um
hier klare Aussagen anhand der
bisherigen wissenschaftlichen Studien
treffen zu können weniger als 2% der
Cannabis Konsumenten bekommen
schwerwiegende seelische
Gesundheitsprobleme zu denen Psychosen
gehören
Psychosen und Schizophrenie betreffen
also wenige Menschen aber wenn es
passiert dann ist es richtig scheiße
kurze Anekdote ich persönlich kenne
jemanden in meinem näheren Umfeld der in
jungen Jahren eine Schizophrenie
entwickelt hat die jetzt nicht mehr
weggeht seitdem ist sein Leben nicht
mehr so wie vorher
wenn man high ist sind die kognitiven
Fähigkeiten auf jeden Fall für einige
Stunden eingeschränkt und wenn wir über
häufiges gewohnheitskissen sprechen dann
sollte man immer davon ausgehen dass man
beeinträchtigt ist für die meisten
sollten diese Beeinträchtigungen nach
ein paar Wochen oder Monaten der
Abstinenz wieder verschwinden für die
meisten gelegenheitskiffer sogar
deutlich schneller als das aber bei
regelmäßigen Konsum entwickeln rund 9%
der Menschen darüber hinaus auch eine
Abhängigkeit bei Alkohol sind das
übrigens 23% und bei Nikotin 68%
was nehmen wir daraus mit die
Risikofaktoren für negative
Langzeiteffekte sind laut praktisch
jeder Studie wie häufig man kifft wie
viel THC man dabei jedes Mal zu sich
nimmt wie lange man das schon so macht
und wie jung man war als man damit
angefangen hat Kinder und Jugendliche
sollten deshalb ganz unbedingt die
Finger von Cannabis lassen aber auch
Erwachsene sollten Cannabis besser nur
in Maßen genießen höchstens ein bis
zweimal pro Woche an freien Tagen eine
kleine Dosis aber Vorsicht beim Dosieren
viele Cannabis Züchter haben in den
letzten Jahrzehnten die Konzentration an
THC in ihren Pflanzen und
Cannabisprodukten deutlich erhöht
gleichzeitig ist die Konzentration von
CBD was die Effekte von THC mildern kann
niedrig geblieben weil Cannabis vom
Schwarzmarkt weiß man nie so genau was
da an Tee hat sie und CBD oder auch an
gesundheitsschädlichen Streckmitteln so
drin ist auf einem Gut regulierten
legalen Markt könnte man hier
Kennzeichnungspflichten einführen die
den Konsum um einiges sicherer machen
würden
deshalb sind auch wir für eine
Legalisierung übrigens CBD mildert zwar
einige Effekte von THC hat aber auch
selbst Wirkungen die zum Beispiel die
Fahrtüchtigkeit einschränken es ist also
leider nicht so dass man unbedenklich
mehr THC zu sich nehmen kann wenn man
gleichzeitig auch mehr CBD zu sich nimmt
insgesamt ist Cannabis weniger schädlich
für die Einzelperson und die
Gesellschaft als Alkohol oder Tabak
deshalb und auch wegen
kombinationseffekten wird auch davon
abgeraten Cannabis mit Tabak zu rauchen
oder beim Konsumieren von Cannabis
Alkohol zu trinken cannabis ist
natürlich eine richtige Droge die kann
Spaß machen mit der muss man aber auch
verantwortungsbewusst umgehen an dieser
Stelle möchte ich euch auch noch auf
eine Möglichkeit hinweisen mit der ihr
die Welt ohne großen Aufwand ein kleines
bisschen besser machen könnte ein Thema
das mir besonders im Herzen liegt ist
die Erhaltung unserer Natur und der
Tierwelt und aus diesem Grund arbeite
ich schon seit längerem mit der
Organisation Planet wild zusammen die
sich für Schutz und Wiederherstellung
von gefähr Ökosystemen einsetzen dafür
führen Sie jeden Monat eine neue
naturschutzmission durch und das beste
sie veröffentlichen alles auf ihrem
YouTube-Kanal so sieht man direkt was
Planet wild vor Ort bewegt in ihrem
neuesten Video unterstützen Sie
beispielsweise die Wiederansiedlung von
Luxen im Harz um diese vor dem
Aussterben zu bewahren möglich gemacht
wird all das von einer Community die die
Projekte finanziert als Unterstützer
sehe ich über Youtube und die Planet App
was mit meiner finanziellen
Unterstützung vor Ort alles bewirkt wird
Planet White ist also keine Organisation
der Mann das Geld gibt und von dem man
danach nie wieder irgendwas hört oder
bei der ihr nicht so genau wisst was mit
eurem Geld eigentlich konkret umgesetzt
worden ist ich persönlich bin
überzeugter Planet wild Unterstützer
weil es mir wichtig ist einen spürbaren
Beitrag zu Erhaltung von Ökosystemen zu
leisten und weil ich nicht einfach
darauf warten will dass andere irgendwas
unternehmen wenn ihr unserer Natur als
Teil einer immer größer werdenden
Community auch etwas zurückgeben wollt
dann werdet unter dem ersten Link in der
Videobeschreibung Planet wild
Unterstützer und wenn ihr noch nicht
vollständig überzeugt seid dann schaut
euch doch einfach das Video hier
ansonsten wie immer vielen Dank fürs
zuschauen und bleibt neugierig euer
Trick